welcome back let's bring in this week's
closer
[Music]
tammy bruce back with us well tammy it
looks like we're gonna be stuck with at
least two more years of nancy pelosi
here she is announcing her re-election
bid and telling us who she's really
fighting for
this election is crucial nothing less is
at stake than our democracy and that is
why i am running for re-election to
congress and respectfully seek your
support when people ask me what are the
three most important issues facing the
congress i always say the same thing our
children our children our children
really the children feel something like
the only good thing nancy antoinette
could ever do for their children is
share some of her ice cream stash and i
was reminded of that this week when i
saw the pictures of biden preparing for
the war he wants to start with russia
by visiting an ice cream shop in
washington but which ice cream shop did
he choose check this out seems that
biden and pelosi are constantly
promoting the same brand of ice cream
jenny's why is that i wondered well we
did a special next revolution ice cream
deep dive and it turns out that the
founder of jenny's ice cream is a bit of
a biden fan in fact she put out a video
for the democrats supporting biden when
he was nominated for president admitted
in a 2017 interview that she had a crush
on biden and named her doc joey b so
there you have it tammy even when it
comes to ice cream for biden and pelosi
it is always about politics it is indeed
and maybe joey b would do a better job
at being president you know maybe the
wrong joe biden is in the white house i
maybe that's maybe that's who we should
have elected was a little dog
look but she's right you notice in that
video she's really above the street
there in san francisco because otherwise
there'd be needles and you know human
human feces so she avoided that by being
above above the neighborhood but she
also is correct when she says it's about
the children actually it is and that is
what my column is about this week which
is that the democrats want to control
your children it's more it's kind of
like that uh twilight zone episode where
it was the martians and they had a book
about how it was they were going to
serve man yeah it was a cookbook and so
you got to think about the context oh my
god when we're thinking about the
children they want to control your
children and they know that that's key
but she's also correct and she sounds
like everything's great it's like you
know the border is open uh but they say
it's closed they say joe biden's really
involved in policy he's not of course
the economy is fabulous uh inflation was
transitory and of course the vaccine
will keep you from spreading uh the
virus so of course everything is fine
that is
as we discussed earlier in the program
this is all they know how to do they lie
blatantly it's the bigger the lie the
more exciting it is and the more ice
cream you get
exactly the other lie just as i'm sort
of thinking about this i mean i i it
wasn't in public but didn't pelosi
herself say
back i can't the last time when there
was a new session and there's a
challenge to it the progressives are
trying to kick her out aoc i remember
was organizing votes against her did
didn't she promise not to run again
after this term i think that was the
implication and of course
everything it doesn't matter with the
politics you lie to get what you want uh
maybe that's something that at least the
progressives you have to admit have been
honest uh we've got to appreciate that
that they weren't like sneaking up on us
and pretending like joe biden did to be
a normal person and then surprise us
with the fact that they're not so at
least that you know they're clear
there's transparency and that's what
we're looking for there is no reason why
she shouldn't run again and this is also
shows the contempt she has for the
people of san francisco the contempt she
has for every american that she knows
she's exposed she you know they we know
we're trying to deal with the insider
trading issues she's done a horrible job
the country is on fire they do want that
and they think we don't care
that's the difference here and you know
look there have been surprises in
politics before uh but really a lot of
good people have left california and so
there's fewer people who might be there
to rebel i just think of eric cantor and
that incredible election where a newbie
got him kicked out of office
so i think she might be feeling pretty
comfortable
that there's really nothing left except
what's inside her freezer and she's fine
with that
exactly and jenny well i mean maybe um
you know joey b would do a better job
maybe even jenny of gennady ice cream
fame who knows yeah exactly no couldn't
be couldn't do any worse uh tammy that
was great good to see you as always
thank you um we'll see what happens i
mean look people are saying that she's
she's running again because she thinks
they're gonna win they're gonna lose who
knows we'll be covering it thank you for
watching hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else